well we woke up this morning to to
dreadful news uh that it looked like was
coming out of merit poll there was a
there was a shelter there with hundreds
of people inside and uh
we know because we've seen pictures of
that shelter with the words children
written in russian on either side of the
end points of that an indication from
the sky
to anybody that this is not a a target
and then there were some reports
overnight that that building had been
hit and for a period of time there was a
lot of worry about the men women and
children who were inside there and
you know what had happened to them and
then this morning some official reports
from the ukrainian authorities
suggesting
that it had been hit but that there that
they had all survived now we're trying
to just get a few more details some
evidence some picture that'll filter
through
as to exactly what the situation is
there but if that's true and if that
pans out then that has been
a miraculous escape and i suppose that
that writing on on the floor is
particularly telling that is how
desperate they are in mario paul now
there is no more they can do than appeal
to the humanity of their enemies by
writing the words children in massive
white letters on the ground to say
please do not bomb this building we are
not the enemy and yet it was struck this
morning here in odessa just a few
hundred miles to the west here another
key city port here uh we were walking up
by sounds of an explosion that rattled
the windows now we've got no more
information other than the sound of it
we don't know whether that was defensive
outgoing fire from the ukraine military
or whether that was something that had
been fired in from the black sea and had
landed somewhere and we felt the
aftershocks that's the situation we're
in here in odessa to all intents and
purposes it is quite quiet here today
people are getting on with their
everyday business but there are huge
defenses being put up now because it is
inevitable i think that at some point
the russians will try and have a go at
this
uh key port city and there are still
families who have stayed here there's a
play park in the city center that we'll
go into in a minute there's their
children playing on swings there are
parents taking their children out for
walks the markets are open
people you get the sense of trying to
get things in while they can because the
situation can change very quickly
and we've seen in mario poll further up
the coast in mikaela another port city
the shells starting to land there as
well and these port cities obviously
strategically very important to the
russian military so
early signs here in odessa although we
can't really be sure what those
explosions were this morning but it
didn't sound good from where i was
sitting and all the city can do is kind
of fortify itself and prepare for what
might come